so how did the opportunity to be on
Celebrity Big Brother come to you they
saw your work in the thank you next oh
yeah
yes so what happened was they saw me and
thank you next and like wow he's really
good at creating things from the early
parts of his career so I was like why
don't I bring Aaron Samuels to the Big
Brother house thank you really got it I
was actually sitting with you I now on
this couch and I leaned over I go hey I
think they want me to do Celebrity Big
Brother should I do it and you go do it
and it's because of you that I'm in the
house literally it's me but we'll take
10% of that 250 when you win it okay
great I'll give you 15% thank you next
no are you nervous about being confined
in the house I'm not nervous about being
confined in the house I'm excited like
how many times do we as people get to
unplug from our world detach get back to
just who you are as a human without
these technology things and without all
these other people just get back to you
and then also get paid and technically
be working you know it's this weird
thing so I'm not like nervous about it
I'm excited to go into the house and
like just have this experience we get to
be one of the 200-some people that I've
ever got to live in the Big Brother
house how cool is that it's like do it
so what's your biggest fear because
everyone else that I've talked to today
is like I don't know how I'm gonna live
without my phone and you're like I'm
great no I'm great
what about your guy okay I'm excited to
be without my phone but there's two
things that I'm nervous about one not
being will talk to my boyfriend which
James which I'm gonna miss and that's
gonna suck because he's really been my
rock through all this like through
getting ready for the show
and getting ready to go into it he's
been my rock rock rock rock telling me
okay you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be fine but the other thing that I'm
nervous about is not being able to post
pictures of my food on Instagram like if
I don't post what salad I had for lunch
how is the world going to go on like
these are the look these are the
questions that matter people it's like
what we worried for you yeah is the even
eating I know
luckily what they're gonna be I'm on you
24/7
whatever yeah thank gosh because what if
I have like a really good like hair day
and I don't post it like that is that
that's that's gonna be a problem like it
doesn't even exist
I'm gonna miss James though how
competitive are you I would say in the
Big Brother house I'm not going to be
the most competitive person I would
agree because it's a game guys we're
having a fun time making a great TV show
like I'm just gonna have a blast however
during the challenges is where I'm gonna
get competitive not because I'm the most
athletic because clearly I'm not I'm a
theater kid like I'm not the most crazy
all right
I've never have driven dribble the
basketball in my life like I'm not that
guy however I just like playing them so
that's where my competition will come
from that's where my competitive side
will come out I just like playing games
I like getting messy yeah I like being a
big kid and doing the challenges that's
what I'm excited for a lot of times when
celebrities like yourself go on these
types of shows then people really get to
know their personalities to kind of fall
in love with them all over again and
certainly you're having like this
resurgence of you those brows they're
back in fashion yeah um what are you
what are your hopes for all of this at
the end when you get out um well the
brows are back baby
yeah the brows are back yeah I'm excited
to go in there and well I think what I'm
hoping for is that people get a chance
to see Jonathan Bennett as Jonathan
Bennett yeah and not as Aaron Samuels
yeah and you know I've embraced it being
Aaron Samuels because it is such a part
of my life however I'm the farthest
thing from him like I'm not anything
like that character I'm not an athlete
I'm a theater kid and I'm not like I'm a
big nerd I'm a big goofy quirky kind of
fumbling like toddler and I'm not like a
cool jock guy so I think people will
hopefully take away from it seeing the
real me and I hope they like that part
which I think that parts more
interesting sometimes on Celebrity Big
Brother some celebrities are like I
can't do this thing you're gonna send
them selves home there any world in
which you're like I'm not in this
like would you leave there is there is
not a single thing that I would not do
on Celebrity Big Brother I will form an
alliance I will get messy there is
nothing I won't do I am here to play
and I'm here to win um did you reach out
to anyone from season one I reached out
to Marissa okay because hey she's a
friend of mine B I'm a huge hairspray
fan yeah and see if you're gonna talk to
someone talk to the winner
she gave me really good advice which was
bring sweatshirts for all the girls
because they're always cold so I packed
a bunch of extra hoodies in my backpack
and that's what I'm gonna use as
collateral and as like crunch the
friendship like oh I'm sorry cuz girls
are always cold they're always like they
have their it's always like I'm so cold
isn't it so cold in here well yeah
you're on Big Brother you know it's
gonna be cold but still they want to
look cute which is great yeah so I'm
gonna bring the hoodies and use that as
like monopoly money like oh don't chase
do you think your friendship with ariana
grande biggest pop star in the world
like helps at all I'm just hoping that
you know I think being friends with
Ariana Grande is definitely gonna help
me in the game yeah Frankie her brother
was a player yeah I did really good he
didn't win he didn't win but I think but
that was before the thank you next that
was before the thank you next I think
it's just they're gonna go in there like
oh my gosh Jonathan Bennett video
Jonathan Bennett music video star yes
definitely want to be friends with him I
think that helps me to celebrity
introduce me I'm hoping that I see well
I'm hoping to people my boyfriend and
Ariana Grande show up in the video
halfway through the game when we get to
say have like videos from our friends
and family I really hope Ariana is the
one that sends me a video and she's like
making something out of your cook yes
she's making something out of the burn
cookbook she's like oh my gosh you're
gonna win look at this fettuccine
alfredo the food situation can be a
little tough yeah if you lose you might
have to eat some SWAT yeah ready for
slop you don't care you know I'm ready
for slop slops gonna be fun
because I don't have to think about what
to cook which I'm really lazy all that
other than the fact that have a cookbook
I don't cook a lot yeah so I'm excited
to like eat the slop if I have to
there's really nothing that I'm not
looking forward to like you want to make
me look stupid and dress me up in silly
costumes game on bring it I'm down cover
me in slime done let's do it what are
you gonna do with that $250,000 when you
win
when I win Celebrity Big Brother I am
going to use the $250,000 to buy a house
because me and my boyfriend want to buy
a house and settle down and start a
family so so bad and so I really am
going to use the money to buy a house
and start a family and that's my goal so
what I'm going in and doing this it's
not for me it's for our family that
we're gonna create what's your strategy
for winning Celebrity Big Brother hi
Julie um
my strategy is go in be friends with
everyone float like a butterfly float
like a butterfly float float sting like
a bee so you go in you float like
Marissa and Ross you're friends with
everyone you played the games oh my god
I'm just Jonathan I'm so funny look I
don't know what I'm doing bananas ah
like you do that and then bow we're
gonna sin your face yep so I'm gonna
float around under the radar as much as
Jonathan Bennett can be under the radar
I know like with that just cuz I'm loud
doesn't mean I'm a target you know later
I should probably tell that it's gonna
be so hard to be quiet you gotta take it
to a - um you just reunited with your
Mean Girls I did star Lindsay Lindsay
Loen did you tell her you ruined the Big
Brother house I did not because we
hadn't confirmed that I was gonna be in
Big Brother when I saw her I am so proud
of Lindsay Lohan just being reunited
with her and shooting her special for
MTV for her Lohan's beach house it was
amazing and she it's the best I've ever
seen her look the best Lindsay has ever
been it's the best she's ever sounded
it's I've never seen her shine this hard
and I'm so proud of her because a lot of
times I mean she's done reality TV and
versions of this before and it's no it's
always been really scatterbrained and
kind of like unfocused so you didn't see
that no Lindsay Lowe Lindsay Lohan is
back everyone get ready because she is a
boss [ __ ] mm-hmm she's a boss [ __ ] and
she do you think she's running it
herself now or do you think mom is still
involved uh I think mom's not involved
at all
I think Lindsay's doing all the work
herself I don't think her mother's
around
I think Lindsay's kind of grabbed the
bull by the horns and as and is doing it
and I'm really proud of her she looks
amazing I've just I've never seen
Lindsay shine this hard and I've never
seen her really take her I don't know
she doesn't take her tell herself so
seriously and she kind of gets it now
and everything's just really coming
together for her sometimes um sometimes
I'm mom and did you ever have a momager
know I didn't help sometimes a momager
can screw things up mm-hmm I'm just
letting you know that that's just mine
yeah I mean I mean you look at like
Britney Spears and all these other
people like they have their like parents
involved and I think Lindsay's mom was
involved you know a lot in the beginning
years when we work together yeah her mom
Dena was around all the time and I think
that helped in some ways and I think
that hurt in some ways and I think
Lindsay kind of taking life into her own
hands right now has really helped her
it's really helped her I love it I can't
wait till you win I'm gonna win hi I'm
gonna win Celebrity Big Brother
thank you probably like top three I
think people that could win yeah you
never know you never know to me but I
feel like I'm in the Final Four for sure
Final Four Final Four amazing
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]